la convulsión social en Perú llegó a las
puertas de los principales lugares
turísticos la iconica ciudadela inca de
Machu Picchu cerró indefinidamente
mientras que aeropuertos y carreteras
intentan ser bloqueados por los
manifestantes que exigen la renuncia de
la presidenta inavoluarte y el cierre
del Congreso luego de más de un mes de
la destitución y detención del
expresidente Pedro Castillo miles de
turistas han sido afectados toman los
aeropuertos no solo somos turistas no
vemos súper perjudicados porque no es lo
mismo no ir a una excursión y disfrutar
de cusco y de otras cosas pues hemos
garantizado el traslado de estos con el
apoyo de la policía desde el rectángulo
desde el sector de pixcacucho hasta la
ciudad de cusco velando Pues por la
integridad física y de todos y cada uno
de ellos que en un aproximado eran un
poco más de 400 personas las regiones
más afectadas económicamente están en el
sur de Perú como Arequipa Apurímac y
cusco lugares que han sido el epicentro
desde enero de la protesta social se
estiman pérdidas diarias de 174 millones
de dólares en ventas especialmente en el
sector de turismo y hotelería que
registra una afectación de alrededor de
un millón 800 mil dólares la
inestabilidad política y social también
ha ahuyentado la inversión de capital en
el sur del país cusco encabeza la lista
con 3.2 millones de dólares seguido de
Arequipa con 1.5 millones y puno con uno
punto cuatro millones de dólares un
golpe duro para la economía peruana cuyo
pib depende en casi un 4% del turismo
luego de una importante recuperación de
este sector en 2022 tras el relajamiento
de las medidas para combatir la pandemia